ultimately all music is an or can be
inspirational fanbase I have now they're
so sophisticated they almost expect me
to do the unexpected I don't look at
myself through other people's eyes one
of my favorite band leaders this Bruce
Springsteen I've washed in so many years
I don't wallow in it I don't spend time
in a place I let myself move on there's
enough things to bring you down we don't
need to Jack our music up that way too I
don't really care so much what people
say about me because it usually is a
reflection of who they are I used him as
a role model and trying to play all the
instruments I kind of wish we got back
to the days where the the music was more
like the soul music at the 60s and 70s
yeah when was born and on a certain day
I'm happy no more birthdays after that
so I don't celebrate birthdays he was an
American singer songwriter record
producer actor and artist he was an
innovator in the music industry and was
known for his flamboyant style and wide
musical range he sold over a hundred
million records worldwide making him one
of the most popular recording artists of
all time
he's Prince and hear his top ten rules
for success how would you describe your
music hmm
what idiom would you put it in the only
thing I could think of because I really
don't like categories but the only thing
I could think of is inspirational and I
think music that is from the heart falls
right into that category people who
really feel what it is that they're
doing and ultimately all music is and/or
can be inspirational and it's that's why
it's so important to let your gift be
guided by something more clear well
first of all I don't know I don't know
who was the one that came up with the
notion that you have to play the same
songs every concert I'd probably fans
yeah you know most of the people that
come see us know they've been to see me
umpteen times
and the only pity is when they bring
their kids and they're trying to show
their kids the experience they had but I
don't know how any of us grow if we just
you know tread water the idea is that we
keep growing and like we were saying
before is the fan base I have now
they're so sophisticated they almost
expect me to do the unexpected and that
gives me a lot of room to challenge
myself as well as it I don't look at
myself through other people's eyes an
interesting discussion with Larry Graham
and not a journalist upstairs about
criticism of music you know if you're
true artist you're using the gift you've
been given from God the end to criticize
a gift from God he's sort of to
criticize God you know you can cut that
any way you want but it's the truth so
yeah you know I looked at the writer I
said I wouldn't criticize your writing
gear I'm not a writer I don't write
books no I wouldn't I was reading that
like you'll go out there with 300 songs
that you might decide at the last minute
to perform that's very risky is it not
the whole band has to be in sync with
you right well they they rehearse a lot
it's a well-oiled machine one of my
favorite band leaders this Bruce
Springsteen of washed in so many years
and I was backstage one night and I saw
him turn around and give a cue and the
band switched on a dime I used to see
James Brown do that Wow you learn from
the best I've always known that God was
my Creator and that without him
why nothing works it works to a point
and then it just kind of deteriorates
entropy takes place when bad things have
happened to you do you blame him
absolutely not yeah how do you explain
how do you resolve it in yourself I
learned from it and I don't I don't
wallow in it I don't spend time in a
place I let myself move on you know
right today I could sit and say I have
animosity towards a record company yeah
a company that owns the rights to my
work you know they're they're
businessmen they're doing what it is
that makes their business successful and
I'm also allowed to do things that make
my business business successful and for
me that would be to own my work so I
just chose to step away from that and
knowing that I sent a nice letter to the
president then president because they
changed a lot weekly during that time
and I told him that I loved him in that
you know I was glad that I had this
experience I was your music it gets you
but in in a good way and I think that's
what music should always do think it
should I believe it yeah there's enough
things to bring you down we don't need
to Jack our music up that way too I mean
there's there's still a way to get anger
and even hate across sometimes in music
but you have to resolve and you have to
show that it's useless to hold these
ideas I don't really care so much what
people say about me because it usually
is a reflection of who they are
for example if people wish I would sound
like I used to sound then it says more
about them than it does me if I change
the lyrics to a song then it begs the
question why do you want me to curse why
do you want me to talk like other people
see kirsten was cool when nobody was
doing it that's a couple of people yeah
yeah like if everybody wears the same
clothes right then it's you know it
ain't cool no more you know you you're
trying to be different one
can't be different by being racy today
it's not interesting anymore
it's a sexiness was in the mind it was
in your imagination when you lose that
then you know like I said it's just old
skiing I use Stevie Wonder as an
inspiration whom I look up to a great
deal and just for the way that he
crafted music and his his connection to
the spirit and boy back then I I used
him as a role model and trying to play
all the instruments and be very
self-contained and keep my vision clear
so word spread very quickly about what I
could do a lot of people knew about it
yeah you know I meet a lot of artists
but in the record industry they tend to
promote things that are more salacious
and hit driven I guess use a term not I
kind of wish we got back to the days
where the the music was more like the
soul music got the 60s and 70s where
Alicia Keys I do I think she's kind of
putting putting it out there as a few
out there the other words where the
lyrics were what made you feel sexy not
the fact that you had barely anything on
yeah you know this reality show nowadays
so wait some once a person gets a firm
grip of life and death and they fully
understand both for example you had how
many birthdays me what do you think well
I know that you had one birthday yeah
when was born and on a certain day you
had no more birthdays after that so I
don't celebrate birthdays so that stops
me from counting days which stops me
from counting time which allows me to
still look the same as I did years ago
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because DJ el magnífico
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of prince's top ten rules
meant the most to you leave in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon